[Music]
at 11 pay more at the grosser but
getting less will tell you how to get
the most
the are you
[Music]
doing we need to acknowledge an
unfortunate mistake that I made and one
of the teases we bring to you before
this program while we're live just after
10:00 I said a word that many people
find offensive I'm truly sorry it was a
mistake on my part and I sincerely
apologize
oh you guys know I love those news
bloopers and that is one of my favorites
that is Sue Simmons back on NBC New York
probably about 20 years ago I don't know
what Chuck Scarboro was doing we never
found out but I just love that freaking
clip anywh who welcome to another Friday
round table extravagan I'm Dave ruin
this is the Ruben report and joining me
today are Michael malice of the your
welcome podcast and the host of the news
and why it matters on Blaze TV Sarah
Gonzalez Michael Sarah how are you crazy
kids good good I can I say for the
record that um when I say that offensive
word I don't apologize I'm not sorry you
actually have a long track record of not
apologizing you fight with people on
Twitter and then you make a point of
saying you are never going to apologize
to them but actually before we get into
it Sarah you have some news of your own
today uh because it sounds like
something big is brewing in Sarah
Gonzalez world yeah I appreciate at that
so the news and why it matters final
episode is going to be tonight at 6 p.m.
Eastern and we are uh we're switching it
over we're going to be Sarah Gonzalez
unfiltered uh starting Monday in a new
time slot uh it's 700 PM Eastern so it's
a little later there's room to be a
little spicier and uh we're going to
have a lot of fun with it and I expect
that both of you will come on the new
show sometime well let's just get
through today you know
well
um all right I'm actually super psyched
to have both of you on the show today
you guys are perfect because Sarah you
are OG born and bred Texan and Malice
you are what you're about a year and a
half into your Texan life after being a
born and bred New Yorker that was Stone
Cold Ruben holy crap I'm I'm proud of
you I thought my trouble was gonna come
from Michael I know you know it's
Friday Luke was puking a little bit last
night I didn't sleep that much it is
what it is you know what are you g to do
it's it's been two and a half years
since I've been a Texan and I got to
tell you that Sue Simmons clip it does
make me remember uh fondly what New York
used to be and uh I've been reading old
books about New York old documentaries
uh so when you see this little Clips it
kind of does take you back but uh I have
no interest in visiting now what it has
become and and I'm delighted that I made
the right choice in becoming a Texan
well that's exactly why I wanted to have
you guys on because to have someone
that's born and bred and someone that
that left New York for the free state of
Texas in light of everything that's
going on so let's just dive right into
it everyone knows that earlier in the
week there was this Supreme Court ruling
5 to4 uh basically stopping Texas from
protecting its own border because the
federal government has been uh totally
negligent about that if not outright
doing it intentionally stopping them uh
here is Governor Greg Abbott Texas
governor Greg Abbott explaining his
decision to defy the Supreme Court
decision Texas is doing is just very
simple and and that is because the Biden
Administration has really truly
abdicated it's responsibility to secure
the border and enforce the laws tesas
very simply is securing the border and
so we put up the razor wire that you
were talking about Bill and we put up
all these barricades that actually have
denied illegal entry uh and as you
pointed out also in that screening that
there are criminals coming across our
border Texas has a right as a state to
stop criminals from coming into our
state to make arrest of those criminals
and we have National Guard as well as
Texas Department of Public Safety
officers who are there to make those
arrests and to deny illegal entry and
Joe Biden actually does have an option
here Joe Biden's option is to enforce
the laws of the United States and stop
this illegal entry Sarah you must be
feeling pretty proud to be a Texan right
now because it seems to me that we have
needed did this fight for a long time
this is overdue uh I'm not a
constitutional lawyer as I said on the
show yesterday but I'm fairly certain
states have every right to protect
themselves especially when the federal
government is not doing their job so how
you feeling today yeah I'm I'm just glad
that Governor Abbott finally did
something we heard a lot of tough talk
for the last three years and I have been
you know I have not been shy in
criticizing the governor when he
deserves it this time I think it's time
to give a little credit where credit is
due he finally
uh put those words into action he
finally once he declared it an invasion
because he's done this several different
times he has declared it an invasion by
saying this is an invasion and then not
followed it up with anything so now
they're finally following it up and I
think um you know dare the federal
government what are you what are you
what are you going to do Joe Biden what
are you going to do are you going to
have your border patrol uh members come
and what start violence they they're in
a bind and honestly it's about damn time
because this is treasonous on part of
the Biden regime this is absolute
treason it is contrary to what is in our
founding documents to what our founding
fathers intended they never intended for
the federal government to completely
neglect their responsibility at the
border and not allow states to be able
to defend themselves and if the Biden
Administration really cared about
Americans they would be thanking Texas
for doing what they couldn't do unless
the plan was to destroy America in which
case they're not so thrilled with it
malice I don't know if you saw a video
that Ron de santis put up yesterday it's
really interesting because since he
dropped out of the presidential race
he's suddenly doing all this stuff on
Twitter he's taking selfie videos it's
like where was that during the campaign
but that aside he he made an interesting
point uh in a little video that he put
up which is that the founders would have
never even signed on to the Constitution
The Federalist Papers all these things
if the basic idea was going to be that
the federal government was going to stop
the States from doing things like it's
actually all backwards right now yeah I
don't really care what the founding
fathers said about anything uh and in
fact the founders would have said that
Governor Abbot should obey what the
Supreme Court says because according to
them the Supreme Court is the final
Authority Supreme as to what the
Constitution says so this is one of
those moments when Boer conservatives
twist themselves in knots when they're
like well we should defy the Supreme
Court you're with me uh the Supreme
Court is a political agency like any
other and I'm thankful that the last
step toward National divorc or one of
them is going to be realized in the
Supreme Court are not holy these are not
you know Saints these are people who are
appointed for partisan reasons and
sometimes they get it wrong so I'm kind
of disappointed in Sarah that she didn't
take the easy line with it's about you
know it's about time that Governor
Abbott stood up for something but I am
more happy than anyone as the person who
got the ball rolling uh for National
divorce starting in 2016 I'm literally
Michael always so careful in my word
choice when I talk about Governor Abit
and you just put it all out there be my
audience my my audience is pretty smart
and they get the reference but the
average person if you said that malice
on another show you know they wouldn't
get it but we got it around here uh well
Sarah what what do you make of that that
the weird position that I suppose right
leaning people are in right now is that
we are the ones that are seemingly going
against the Supreme Court when actually
generally speaking we're the ones that
like to believe in you know separation
of powers that the courts you know
usually do good things that kind of
thing well I mean I think that two
things can be true right I mean while
Michael is saying is absolutely correct
um the federal government is also
neglecting their constitutional
responsibility to protect our borders
and keep our border Sovereign so they
you know it's kind of like I hate to
break it down to um my my kids
conversations my kids fights but it's in
the case of who started it I mean the
federal government very clearly is
acting unconstitutionally and if you
don't have the Supreme Court the highest
court in the land as Michael pointed out
acting in a an objective manner I mean
number one the state has to do what it
has to do to protect its own borders and
let the chips fall where they may later
but number two I would also say um to
Michael's point you know you also have
Joe Biden uh defying the Supreme Court
when he's allowing all of this student
loan debt repayment so when you have the
other side who doesn't play by the rules
you have to finally decide for yourself
what point what's the point in playing
by the rules when I playing my opposing
team doesn't play by the same rules they
don't care what the rules are and I just
don't think you're ever going to get
anywhere playing by rules that the other
team doesn't follow oh my I'm can I say
I'm I'm ecstatic to hear you say that
because that is precisely the anarchist
position that laws are just you know
Implements of power and there's nothing
objective and there's no moral reason to
follow them if they don't further your
interest so amen Sarah welcome aboard so
well that was also why I wanted to have
you on because it's not just that you're
a New York guy who moved to Texas
because of covid but but a lot of what's
happening right now I think lends itself
to the arguments you've been making for
years M so when when you mentioned
National divorce look I don't like
giving the idea of national divorce or
Civil War energy however as someone that
moved from California obviously to
Florida that now I'm happy that Dan
santis is my Governor again we see this
Stark difference in blue and red and all
that stuff like is this really where you
think we should be going at this point
well I guess it's a stupid question I
guess the answer is yes well this is
where we should have been going for a
long time and I don't understand how you
could sit there with a pun intended
straight face and say that as a
Floridian you should we should be under
the thumb I'm serious of New York DC and
La that to me is absolutely crazy and
there's further steps uh as you very
well know to diminish the Electoral
College and have it more of a popular
vote and if that is the case case then
it will be entirely a federal government
run by people who run in cities
something which you know we still I'm in
Austin you're in Miami respectively but
they do not carry the weight that new
culturally that and politically that New
York City DC Chicago and La do so I'm
absolutely delighted that this is
happening I'm delighted that more people
are understanding that the federal
government is more of a threat to them
than Putin or Beijing um and I don't see
most importantly and I'm curious to hear
you guys thoughts I don't see a way for
them to turn this car around well first
off to be clear Alice I think you know I
don't want New York and Cali to have
anything to do with my life in Florida I
just think that there's a general you
know we start the Civil War talk and we
just don't know where up where it ends
up so I just want to be personally a
little bit careful about that but let
let me throw a diversity hire Karen Jean
Pierre uh explaining what the
uh explaining what the administration
might do Homeland Security Department
has asked for access to this park that
is now currently in dispute it doesn't
seem like they've gotten it uh they now
are allowed to cut down razor wire some
Democrats are saying the president needs
to federalize uh the Texas National
Guard so look something that could
happen I mean look I'll say this uh you
know the border patrol agents are now as
you said allowed to cut through the wire
because of what the Supreme Court laid
out it's it's unfortunate that we had to
go there it's unfortunate that there is
a governor in Texas governor Abbott who
has politicized this issue of what's
happening on the border and it's not
making people's lives safer it's
actually making it harder for law
enforcement the at the border to do
their job and so we have been very clear
we want to make sure we get something
done at the border that's why we've been
having these conversation with Senate
Republicans and democrats for the past
several weeks to come up with a
bipartisan agreement to deal with the
border and look if that the governor is
not interested in that Governor Abbott
is not interested in that he wants to
politicize an issue and he's not helping
communities he actually isn't and he's
actually putting border patrol agents In
Harm's Way by doing what he's doing I'm
not going to speak to any actions that
the president might take may not take
but we have been very clear on this I
mean everything she said there is a
confusion or an outright lie or
backwards but Sarah to try to give the
devil his due here to me it seems that
what Democrats think or at least what
this Administration thinks is that
border Patrol's job is to process
immigrants not to protect the Border
like that's actually what they believe
and if we acknowledge that then we can
start fighting with them properly does
that does that seem fair to you yeah
that is what pisses me off so much every
single time I hear these people Trot out
and repeat these lines that border
patrol needs more resources not to
protect you and me not to protect actual
Americans just to process these unvetted
strangers and allow them into the
Interiors of our country it is
absolutely reprehensible I'm old enough
to remember a time when Border Patrol
was actually there to enforce the law
and keep these people out instead
they're just glorified processors where
they give them a little note and say hey
promise that you'll really super pinky
promise that you're going to be out of
court in the year
2032 and we'll just really really hope
that you show up wink wink I mean it's
disgusting and you have these people I
just heard a story the other day of a
woman I believe her name was Tammy nobl
whose daughter was autistic
developmentally disabled who was killed
strangled to death by an MS13 gang
member because border patrol and the
Department of Homeland Security is not
doing their damn job and I'm so tired of
hearing this cuz here's what you'll hear
from the sorry I'm on a rant here's what
you'll hear from the left guys here's
what you'll hear from the left okay we
need more even from the the NYC mayor
Eric Adams and and all of these Democrat
lawmakers who are Sanctuary cities until
all the brown people show up at their
doorstep and they're like wait a second
we didn't plan for this to happen here's
what they say they don't say close the
border they say we need more Federal
resources thrown our way to house these
people we're going to get to a point
where there's geographically no place
else for them to go and these people are
so disgusting that they think that
throwing more of our taxpayer money is
going to solve the problem when really
it's just going to I mean it's
disastrous it's going to be disastrous
for decades with these people we have to
have someone in office who is willing to
say we have to start mass deportations
now I believe that's what we call Sarah
Gonzalez unfiltered debu on Monday
malice what do you think the argument is
like if you were in the white house
right now and there's that elderly man
with dementia there and the diversity
higher and the and mayorcas with the
eyebrows and all the people if they're
sitting in there what do you think
they're saying to each other right now
do they think they're doing the right
thing well they know that this is
something that benefits the Democratic
party both in the short term and long
term uh they're not incorrect at all uh
you know obviously anyone who has a kid
on American soil that kid is
automatically a citizen so that you know
this you know I think we all remember in
2016 when some horrific corporate
journalists yelled at president Trump
for using the term anchor baby and he
goes no no I'm gonna use the term anchor
baby uh but you know I I'm saying this
is an immigrant um this is something
that if a nation does not when we came
over we had to have a family sponsor us
to be responsible like meaning they were
accountable now there's just absolute no
accountability because we don't know who
half these people are they're throwing
out their ID cards you know
intentionally I'm all for
humanitarianism to a point but if you're
not able to shift between who's coming
over because they're fleeing some sort
of genocide or who's coming over because
they're a a military age male who just
wants to have an easy life and and and
not going to be able to integrate into
society which is going to lead to very
harmful consequences this is a serious
concern so as to your question what
they're doing in the White House I I
don't think they know what to do because
this is the first time I think for a
very long time when a republican
Governor any Governor pretty much has
stood up to the federal government to
such an extent I'm delighted by this so
they're I'm sure their phones are
ringing off the hook uh here in Austin
with Governor Abbott and the Beautiful
Thing is both House and Senate are a tie
so you don't have the space to any make
any kind of big moves like the Congress
is effectively crippled uh so this is
really a wonderful time for things to
escalate in Direction it needs to go in
my opinion it does feel like something
is turning right now like this issue is
just so damn obvious when you see these
25 to as you said like 40y olds all male
running in it's in light of what
happened in Israel on October 7th who
the hell are these people what are their
intentions but malice I'm going to give
you some low hanging fruit here because
this map has been making the rounds on
Twitter uh of what people of what people
are saying kind of like the split would
look like that these Southern States uh
would kind of align together and that
maybe it could leak a little further
west something like that part I disagree
Texas is going to be its own Nation but
I will say one other thing something
that's actually key in Germain I think
it was 25 other state Governors publicly
said we're siding with Governor Abbott
that is a huge new step and a huge
precedent because many of these aren't
some former Confederate states so they
can't say oh this is all about slavery
these it reaches all the way to the
northern New Hampshire being one of them
so I'm very excited there is a majority
of States already who knows who else is
going to join on board to be like we're
with Abbot and when you have a majority
of the states against the federal
government that also is unprecedented
territory for the Biden Administration
it also puts the Democrat Governor on
alert because if you're H up in New York
and everyone's watching New York fall
apart and you won't sign on to this
thing it's like oh you're actually the
one and then and then you're telling
everybody keep coming here so I guess
good for us live in the free state of
Texas for you guys Florida for me let
let's move over to uh the other thing
that's happening right now which is that
Donald Trump is back in business he's
here whether you like it or not and uh
yes he's Hitler and a fascist and all
that stuff check out this was a I'm not
going to show you all three minutes of
it just a little bit of Joy Reed
starting her show yesterday and uh I'd
also like everyone to focus on her hair
because I don't think it's natural and
we begin tonight with Fascism and how it
takes root now it isn't usually a
dramatic stormm the palace coup like we
saw on January 6th it's more often a
deal a bargain between the would be
dictator and the establishment both
political and media who believe that
wielding actual political power will
take him it's usually what we often it
will actually will actually tame him I
should say it's actually what we often
get wrong about fascism and describing
the connections between interwar Europe
and the present day us scholar John
gance writes quote we have this image in
our heads of the fascist rise to power
that comes from fascist propaganda but
it is much more political than that in
viiew of gans's new book in the American
Prospect Rick pearlstein also Notes The
crucial role of the quote responsible
conservatives who made their peace with
the strong man believing he could be
controlled pearlstein recalls Germany's
Vice Chancellor France Bon papen the
architect of the 1933 Coalition that
made Adolf Hitler the chancellor when
the people around pen voiced their
concerns about putting Hitler in power
papen said in two months we'll have
pushed Hitler so far into the corner
that he'll squeal the thought that these
men Could Be Tamed is what we're seeing
right now in the presidential election
year where politicians journalists and
voters speak of a dangerous person
getting reigned in once back in power
and those who are legitimately afraid of
this outcome are being quiet about it so
Sarah what's the deal with her hair no
just kidding um wait can I answer that
it's
cultural yeah what is it it is cultural
appropriation yes from
Karen that's Karen here cancel that
woman for God's sakes the actually
though the of course okay Hitler fascism
all that stuff Sarah do you think it you
can see them busting out the same
Playbook again I mean we've been through
this this is what you guys did that led
to the rise of the guy in the first
place you're doing it again it's leading
to the rise this time and by the way you
guys are the ones that are trying to
take him off the ballot and hang him up
in court and do sort of fascist things
do you think it's going to work again I
don't I don't I don't especially at a
time maybe uh if we had not lived
through three years of Joe Biden but
we're living through a time where you
know it's so cute when they throw out
the term fascism while their own party
are you know uh trying to imprison their
own political opponents while their own
party are throwing people uh into prison
for decades because you know they put
their feet up on Nancy Pelosi's desk
while they are you know targeting
pro-life protesters for peacefully
protes ing the act of abortion I mean
you have really reprehensible people in
charge I call them the Biden regime for
a reason so it's just really cute to
hear this it may have worked if we
hadn't been living at a time where the
average American doesn't care what you
call someone else what they care about
is how much it costs to fill up their
gas tank how much it costs when they buy
groceries at the grocery store uh how
much their mortgage rate has increased
their their interest rates and that's
what the average American is seeing and
feeling and I just just don't think name
calling is going to work this time and I
will also add Dave I know you guys know
this I and I know that you saw it but if
it was Ronda STIs they would have called
him the same things they were already
preparing to do that they were already
throwing in the seeds to plant so that
they could start calling Ronda santis
Hitler and a fascist and alt-right and
all of the same things that they call
Donald Trump it's all an illusion none
of it is real and they know it's not and
I just don't think it's going to work
this time no they were prepping the the
disantis thing they were basically
calling him Hitler with the calculator
like at least the orange guy's an idiot
but this guy knows what he's doing it's
going to be even worse mice what what do
we do about this like information gap of
the type of person that watches MSNBC
which of course is dwindling numbers and
we get the fight between Legacy Media
and online media but that there still
are millions and millions of people that
buy this stuff and they're they're
living in an alternate universe and we
got to save them or forget about them or
institutionalize them what do we do
you're the one who wants to continue
being in a country with them I want to
live in free Texas I'm not even kidding
there's no getting through them by your
own admission uh here's the other thing
let's take for let's just take them
arguments seriously for a second if you
regard Trump as a hitler-like figure and
your strategy last time didn't stop him
it is incumbent on you to do everything
in your power to think of a new strategy
to take this guy on because we're
looking at the destruction of one's
country and genocide but the fact that
they're just saying the same things over
and over means they're not particularly
I believe that these corporate
journalists are scared when the first
one leaves the country you know I mean
if Hitler's coming to power even just
the threats so many people not just
Jewish people are like I got to get the
heck out of Dodge because this is
getting really scary really fast they're
not selling their houses in you know uh
uh Cape cot or whatever they don't care
because it's not going to affect them
they're full of they're completely full
of crap uh I do think though um to the
point about the hair Karen is the swing
voter in this country yeah and Karen is
it's going to be kind of hard to
convince Karen to vote for someone who
is a felon so this ideaa that you know
it's going to be a cakewalk for Trump is
not at all accurate they got him out the
White House in 2020 so the concept that
like well it's just going to be a given
that in 2024 uh you know after three
years people are going to go vote for
Trump that's not obvious to me at all
and it's not at all obvious to me that
Biden's going to be the nominee because
it's going to be very easy and I've said
this before hold on if they pull Biden
they can put in Hillary and Hillary had
already gotten Millions more votes than
Trump in the wrong States but I'd rather
start out with someone who you people
have voted for before who have millions
more votes and now it's just a matter of
accounting and putting the votes right
right place with nuum as the VP so they
don't have to defend the California
record that would be a very strong
ticket for the Democrats and then she
wouldn't have to defend Biden she could
just throw Biden's record on the bus I'm
with you that it's that Suburban kind of
white woman or these disaffected libs
that have kind of woke up over the last
few months that those are the only
people who might move and the issue with
Trump is that they don't seem to want
Trump which which is why I would like
Trump to maybe soften The Stance a
little bit we we'll get to who's going
to who might run if they get rid of
Biden in just a sec but I thought this
video was really interesting so there's
this guy Dean Phillips who's a
congressman in Minnesota who is running
as a Democrat and uh he's quickly
realizing kind of like RFK Jr realized
that the Democrats are complete lunatics
he had a rally a couple days ago I think
this is from two days ago and it was
near a trump rally and he wandered in
Democrat running for president learning
what the DNC is all about how corrupt
they are decides to wander into a trump
rally check this out we have a crisis of
participation and I got to tell you guys
I went to a Donald Trump rally a couple
nights ago never been to one uh I had an
event across the street I saw the line
of people waiting in the cold for hours
and I thought what the heck you know I'm
going to be a leader who actually
invites people doesn't condemn them met
probably 50 Trump people waiting in line
every single one of them thoughtful
hospitable friendly all of them so
frustrated that they feel nobody's
listening to them but Donald Trump a
diverse crowd people who had never been
to a trump event before my party is
completely delusional right now Sarah
that is exactly what happened to me when
I was on the fence about Trump I was
driving through Los Angeles on Wilshire
Boulevard and there was a trump rally
and I was like you know what let me just
go and see what happens and it was a
joyous festival with American flags and
Latinos for Trump and gays for Trump and
blacks for Trump and everybody was happy
and nice um I've also I said once to
build AR on his podcast that he would be
welcomed more at a trump rally than if
he went to a progressive rally like an
AOC rally and he even agreed with me uh
I suppose none of this surprises you
yeah no of course not and I I mean I
want to add to Michael's point about the
Suburban moms because of course I think
their votes very much are still in play
um and here is why I understand your
point about they're not going to want to
vote for a felon and I agree with you
but there is the unprecedented basis of
but we all know he's not actually a like
they're weaponizing the system against
him to call him a felon so that they can
say see you don't want this felon to be
your president and so you know I mean
you're working with the other side who
is just operating to try to um I'm I'm
trying are we on YouTube we are but say
say whatever you want we're on Rumble
and locals you're good you know there's
a lot of procedures that are happening
um to children that the Biden
Administration is pushing for you know
you're living at a time where parents
are getting their their rights taken
from them if they don't affirm their
child's gender and so I do think that
there is a lot that is still in play
another issue that I think is still in
play is the minority vote uh Dave you
pointed out Latinos for Trump and blacks
for Trump and all of that and I saw a
tweet from the rapper Meek Mills not
that long ago and he retweeted a trump
vake clip where they were you know they
were at some rally and they were talking
and he retweeted it and and he said you
guys are going to be real surprised when
you find out who black people people in
poverty are voting for this time around
now am I putting a whole lot of stake in
that no because historically black
people should have started voting
against Democrats a very long time ago
but I do think that it it may take this
Rock Bottom Administration for these
people to wake up and say you know
finally we've been fooled and I don't
just mean black people I mean the
Suburban moms as well I mean these are
these are un Uncharted territories this
is an unprecedented time that we are in
and that's why I wonder if the Suburban
vote is still in play because I look at
this and I'm like no freaking way my I
want my kids to go through another four
years of this Administration I will vote
for anything else malice is is the rub
though on that that everything I agree
with everything Sarah just said right
there with with the kids in the Border
like parents are waking up to all of
this nonsense but that sliver of people
that we're talking about that white
Suburban Woman They we just know they
have a massive aversion to Trump
and they're the ones also who have
munals by proxy who are for the stuff
with the gender with their kids so they
are the Swing Vote so Sarah's completely
correct like you can maybe you can see a
lot of them are going to be you know
anti-trump a lot of them are going to be
for Trump you know blah blah blah so
they're they're they're the ones who are
going to decide the election unless it's
a landslide one way or another which I
can easily see happening uh uh as well
but I'm just going to tweak Sarah a
little bit this is not the there's a
joke Reagan used to make how uh he was
there's two people walking in Soviet
Union red square and one them goes to
the other is this it have we reached
full communism and the other goes oh no
it gets much worse so for you to say
this is Rock Bottom I know you're not g
disagree with me it can get a lot worse
I agree I agree you're right I just my
point is my point is I I feel like there
are a lot of Americans that are
frustrated like I am that say you're
right to your point Michael that like
we're not at rock bottom but like what
the hell happens if he gets another four
years look how bad it's gotten in
three let's jump over to what could
happen in four years because obviously
we do have this uh Republican process
happening right now Nikki Haley sticking
around which is sort of interesting here
is uh her celebrating her second place
finish in New Hampshire a couple days
[Applause]
ago with Donald Trump Republicans have
lost almost every competitive election
we lost the Senate we lost the house we
lost the White House we lost in 2018 we
lost in 2020 and we lost in
20122 the worst kept secret in politics
is how badly the Democrats want to run
against Donald
Trump Trump's the loser he's a
loser I know that neither one of you
love Nikki Haley uh but I don't think
she's completely wrong about that
specifically and if I was Nikki Haley
and I was running right now I would
certainly you know everyone's saying oh
she should drop out and it's a waste of
money it's like I don't know why you
care about the donor's money suddenly
but of course you have to stick around
to South Carolina like if I was her of
course you do mice what do you think
well first of all I don't think it's of
course because getting your ass handed
to in your home state is something
that's really bad for your career long
term and this is one so that's kind of a
big deal why she might drop out she
clearly doesn't think that's going to
happen well we don't we don't know it's
a month away and the fact that Tim Scott
the senator from that state Endor Trump
is no deal but I'm going to disss with
her a little bit in terms of losing for
a lot of conservatives and they're
completely correct if Nikki Haley wins
the Republican party is lost because
it's lost all the things that matter to
it you know she it supports trans kids
she's a huge warmonger I don't think
she's particularly physically
conservative what would this woman gain
you other than having a completely uh um
castrated Senate and House supporting a
horrible you know demon in the white
house why would conservatives want this
that's not a win that's a complete loss
for them so even though Tech and I'll
just point out something else that I've
called and I'm positive you both will
agree I was very much for Federman over
Oz and every Republican and conservative
I've spoken to now has seen that I was
right so a lot of times just because
someone there are many reasons why you
might prefer a Biden Administration to a
Nikki Haley at the very least because
you'd have space in Congress to fight
the administration instead of them all
having to get their ducks in a row and
do whatever she wants malice I'll give
credit where credits du because I think
you said that on this show before that
election and we'll try to find the clip
maybe we'll put that up um Sarah you
know there seems to be this idea that
Nikki is actually just sticking around
because Trump's going to select her as
VP the Bas obviously hates it but it
would kind of be within Trump's like bag
to like poke them in the eye and be like
I need those Women Voters that we were
just talking about and maybe she can
deliver them and bring some donors along
the way yeah the thing with Trump though
is that he is just such a a loyalist he
values loyalty overall and Nikki Haley
has been disloyal to him for too many
years in my opinion for Trump to turn
around and decide that he wants to to
use her as the VP pick I see if if it's
a woman I would see more of like a Sarah
Huckabee Sanders someone who has been
you know loyal to him um but I mean oh
also if Nikki Haley the longer she
continues the worse it's going to get
for her the less and less likely it's
going to be for Donald Trump to pick her
because it's just pissing him off that
she's staying in the race at this point
she's the last one um and to Michael's
point about all of this just this these
neocon conservatives who just refuse to
go away it's terrifying to me I do take
a little bit of uh encouragement in the
fact that apparently a lot of the the
Iowa caucuses who voted for Nikki Haley
were in fact Democrats same thing with
New Hampshire so maybe it's not the full
20% but it does seem to be like there's
this 20% of people within the party who
just want to vote for these these
warmongers and you know these people who
are not conservative at all and so it is
a little bit scary for me to see how
many people are are okay with this type
of person in the party I had thought
that we had gone away from that you know
we told Chris Christie we didn't want
him we told ASA Hutchinson we didn't
want him we told Mike Pence we didn't
want him and Nikki just seems to be the
last one standing and uh you know maybe
that's because she has all of these
Democrat donors who are bankrolling her
which I think should tell you a lot when
you have black rock and you have all of
these Democrats who say we have to do
everything we can not to have Trump in
power and they are instead funding Nikki
Haley's campaign I think that that tells
you all you need to know about Nicki
Haley ma malice is is the rub in the
ointment on what Sarah just said there
that even though it is true that a huge
amount especially in New Hampshire of
Independence and apparently Democrats
actually voted for Nikki is the issue
there that when Trump gets to the
general those people don't seem to like
him and he is going to need some of
those people again largely women if he
is going to win
sure I mean but the point in our in our
kind of binary political system if you
vote for me holding your nose you vote
for me because you love me it doesn't
really matter the vote counts the same
so they're going to have to go somewhere
other than I guess if RFK is on board
but he's always had a problem with you
know Democrats Independence that's
nothing new but the point is he's
leading I think by double digits among
Independents against President Biden at
this moment in time and the campaign
hasn't even gotten started I don't think
things are going to get particularly
better for Biden as the year uh goes
along especially because there seems be
no possibility of any legislature
passing through Congress and I think
Governors are going to be more
emboldened to take on the federal
government and he just doesn't seem like
a like if you had Hillary Clinton in the
white house you could see her very
easily sitting behind that that desk and
berating Governor Abbot Joe Biden is
weak in At Bernies like you can't even
follow his train of thought which is
really bad for the Democrats who want to
have someone who's gonna be a strong
leader to stand up to this dictator
Donald Trump they don't have that and
kjp is not exactly a Shining Light of
intellect in in the in the white house
toley so I I think things are going to
get and he's going to be a punching bag
for Trump as the year goes on it was
different in 2020 because there was
covid people were scared but now there's
no reason for him to be hiding in that
basement well you given me a perfect
segue to the last thing I wanted to
touch on which is Will Biden be the
nominee so there's some interesting
stuff we've got some info from value
tainment uh Michelle Obama rumored to
have plans to replace Joe Biden in the
2024 election a New York Post columnist
alleges that there are plans underway
for Michelle Obama to enter the 2024
presidential race this summer as
President Joe Biden's approval rating
continues to fall and Donald Trump
continuously outperforms him in the
polls many observers including prominent
members of Congress argue such a
scenario is increasingly likely
additionally a poll from August found
that the majority of Democrats would
prefer Michelle over Joe the writer New
York City based socialite and gossip
columnist Cindy Adams claims sources
have told her that Obama has has pulled
donors to gauge the reception of a
campaign Trail intervention apparently
there is a plan to have Biden announce
in May that he is not running and have
the former first lady take the
nomination without a primary vote during
the DNC convention in August in a
different column Adams claims that
Michelle Obama sent a survey to
democratic leaders asking how they would
feel about her running additionally she
reports that in the summer of 22
Michelle held a meeting in New York City
with major headed fund uh hedge fund
CEOs and told I am running and I am
asking for your support during an
appearance on J shett podcast in early
January Michelle remarked that she is
quote terrified about the 2024 election
uh Sarah that Cala lady can't be happy
about this like how are they going to
push like it does seem obvious to me
that the guy could fall today like while
we're on air it could all end but they
still have to get rid of Camala and uh
that's going to be a real issue yeah I
mean here's the only way that I can see
that playing out easily it Optics wise
is if kamla Harris something happens to
Joe Biden uh you know God forbid that he
just heels over and dies but even not
even if not um they could just say you
know what there's some health issues and
he's going to go ahead and step away
kamla has her time in the spotlight for
like nine months and then she actually
just voluntarily says I've had my time I
was the first woman president and I'm
going to go off and do something else
and then Michelle Obama uh gets past the
torch I now having big mik I'm sorry
Michelle um up there scares the hell out
of me um it's not you catch that M did
you C did you catch the reference there
I caught it I caught it you got it you
got it okay it's not something that I
want to will into existence because
that's terrifying to me but it I mean
they need to do something that's the
point the Democrats know they have to do
something whether it's Gavin Nome or
Michelle Obama they know they cannot run
this walking potato for another four
years but the potato won the potato's in
the office and that in potato won by
hiding the potato won by
hiding years well but but he hasn't hid
for the last three years we've seen him
sure I I mean I know you agree with me
that it's not a given that he's gonna
lose like at all especially if Trump is
no it's not a given but no it's not but
I think that there's so much it isn't it
scary though that like the time that we
have left we we all know there are so
many things hanging out there that so
many things could
that could change the game well I mean
Trump's no spring chicken either and I
made this you know when you're like 63
250 at that age you know yeah he looks
good but things can happen all the time
and I don't wish for bad things for
almost anyone other than corporate
journalists but I I think this to the
point I think this whole Michelle Obama
thing is a complete Boomer fantasy uh
they just have this fixation Michelle
Obama I know where it comes from the
idea that if Biden is incapacitated that
she'd be the plan B is crazy she's never
won any elected office she has no
political resume much to speak of and
the fact that the the claim that
everyone the Democratic party who has
paid their dues would just step aside
for her is nuts if she wanted to have it
she would could have had it in 2020 um
so I think this is completely false if
this survey had actually happened in
writing it would have leaked and it
wouldn't have leaked through Cindy Adams
um so I I'm sure she's very concerned
and so on and so forth but by all
accounts she hated her time in
Washington uh I don't know why she want
to put her I I mean would you want to
run against President Trump as a mom and
knowing what he's going to say about you
and your kids I mean forget it so and I
don't see how she's going to tell
Hillary and KLA Harris oh just step
aside Michelle got this that that's not
gonna happen can I can I add one more
thing to that Dave sure uh she also to
to Michael's point I mean she lives on
Martha's Vineyard like she has they they
they've got their Netflix deal like 30
Acres on the water not worried about
climate change money right like right um
they've made their money they're they're
very comfortable she's living the
elitist life that I'm sure she always
dreamed of living so I don't know why
she would walk away from that to do it
um I still think that they're trying to
prepare Gavin Newsome to uh to take to
take charge there but yeah I don't if
you're if I'm Michelle Obama I don't
want to do that I'd rather just live my
you know live my fancy life I have one
final question for you guys which is
what are you doing in the free state of
Texas on this weekend what does one do
in Texas on an insurrection weekend
malice you first should I go out maybe
I'll go out and get another
gun that would be nice you're a first
time gun owner in Texas right you did
not have sir gun and I got a Mada which
is the gun that the IDF uses very nice
very ni Sarah I know you have many guns
what what will you be doing this weekend
in Texas as all of this
unfurls yeah well you know the here's
the problem Dave I did have many guns
and then I lost them in a really tragic
voting accident so darn it I don't have
any more in case the federal government
is wondering but um we're just going to
hang out hang out with the kids yeah
yeah hang out with the kids and uh you
know it's cold for us in Texas which
means it's like 50 degrees so we're
hoping that it warms up so we can go
outside and play on the BL hold on if
it's called now wait till I call I on
you Gonzalez we're gonna solve this
problem yes yes and Malice doesn't have
any guns either and either do I or
anyone else in the studio and
communication postgame show at Ruben
report. locals.com and 30 seconds thanks
guys I'll see you soon thank you want to
do this and spend a night in the Oscar
meire Wier mobile you can do so August
1st and the third and it's it's actually
not bad it's $136 a night wow there you
go good deal a romantic night in a
Winter mobile what sorry all
[Music]
right